you're going to do a couple of songs
that i'm very excited about
i'm very excited about that take a few
phone calls
all right yes kimberly i love you my
husband's in my
wedding song whereas head over feet we
love that song i mean that's some song
but how do you how do you write that
like i mean you're just a kid
and you and what do you sit in your
bedroom one day and you start what do
you like write poetry first and then you
put it to music
no this song i was in the studio with
glenn ballard i was writing it with and
um
just about 20 or 25 minutes just all
came out like a conversation but
you know when you're writing a letter it
just writes itself wow it's kind of like
that
i have written letters nothing ever
comes out yeah nothing like that anyway
nothing anybody would want to publish
maybe we should do that now
that would be an excellent uh what do
you think pretty professional huh
so pro all right so you um so this is
their wedding song
i had no choice
but to hear you you stayed in
your case time and again
and i thought about it
[Music]
and you treat me like
i'm a princess and i'm not
used to liking
i had and you asked how my
day was you've already won
me over in spite
of me and don't be loned if i
fall head over
feet and don't be surprised if i love
you
for all that you are
i couldn't help it
it's all your fault
and your love is thick
and it swallowed me whole and you're so
much braver than i give you credit for
and that's not lipsticks
you've already won me over
in spite of me and don't be longed if i
fall head over
feet and don't be surprised if i love
you
for all that you are
i couldn't help it
it's all your fault
and you are the bearer
of unconditional things and you held
your breath and the door for me
and thanks for your patience
my
you're the best listener
that i've ever met and you're my
best friend best friend with bad
fats what took me so
long
and i never felt
this healthy before and i've never
wanted something rational
and i am air now
[Music]
[Applause]
in spite of me don't be alone if i
[Music]
no
high
oh yeah look at you